so has the sci-fi channel really just
commissioned a spin-off show of stargate
welcome to scitrek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
the quick answer to this video really is
no
the ark is a new tv show that has been
commissioned by the sci-fi channel and
we'll be on our screens hopefully end of
this year early next year
but where these rumors come about that
this is somehow linked to stargate or
that this show will exist within the
stargate universe
well basically the show is being
produced by dean devlin and jonathan
glassner now if you are fans of stargate
you'll know both of those names very
well jonathan glassner was very
important in the sg-1 series and dean
devlin wrote and helped to produce the
original stargate movie dean devlin has
also
produced and written many other sci-fi
projects over the years so apparently
some youtube channels have got two plus
two and equaled four and i have had
several messages asking me
is stargate coming back a little bit
sneakily now amazon own the rights to
the stargate franchise and the sci-fi
channel could not produce a tv show
without their blessing but that hasn't
stopped some people from suggesting that
yes this is actually a show that maybe
won't call itself stargate but that does
exist within the stargate universe again
it's not true
basically all you have to do is look at
the plot for this new tv show called the
ark and you'd understand that it could
not exist within the stargate universe
at all it wouldn't need to
basically the plot and it is a very
interesting plot i'm looking forward to
this tv show quite a lot
is that basically the human race needs
to spread amongst the stars they are
trying to seed planets outside of our
solar system to ensure the survival of
the human race and the first of these
big starships going out to see these
planets the ark
has a devastating accident or system
failure just as it's about to land on a
planet and
catastrophe ensues
obviously in the stargate universe the
planets have already been seeded with
humanity we're everywhere but also
because of the stargate network if we
decided to start transferring millions
of people and seeding other planets then
it would be easily done through the gate
rather than on very very large arc
starships it would be much quicker and
much easier and also we have starships
already in the stargate universe and we
would just use them
so yes these conspiracy theories that
stargate is being sneakily put back on
our screens and even though that won't
be called stargate it really is are not
true i haven't seen these youtube videos
myself but if you come across them
please send me the link i'd love to have
a look um but i'm absolutely certain
this new tv show called the arc will
actually be a really good show it's
going to be on the sci-fi network which
have a good history of making and
producing tv shows like this it's
getting a 12 episode run so a reasonable
run as well let's see what dean devlin
does with this one
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification really helps us out you can
join the channel for a small fee and
become a sidetracker and help me produce
more material you can also join us on
facebook the link is in the description
thanks very much guys and i will see you
really soon
you